- So what I do, I do in neuroscience.
So basically, my lab,
main focus is to build these
big, incredible microscope
in order to look directly
in to the mouse brain
or other animals brain.
I do mouse things and stuff,
so that's why I say mouse,
but you can see into a
monkey's brain, a fish brain,
sea elegans brain, like worm's brain.
And the idea is I like to
see the neural activity
and figure out what's
going on in the brain
and understand the algorithms
that the brain is using
in order to encode information
and also decoding information
from its own coding
and then to perceive and
be able to move, et cetera.
So it's very interesting.
And today, basically, I'm
gonna give you a broad tour
of how my things look like.
I'm gonna explain to you
a smaller experiments
that I'm running right now.
And hopefully, we get to the
point that I can show you
how to put the animals
and we do experiments.
So, I'm gonna share the
other screen that I have.
So what I do is just, I look
at the mouse's brain directly,
but the important thing is
to look at the mouse's brain
while the animal is executing a behavior.
So I have a pretty, specific behavior
because I'm studying how
the brain encodes for time,
for how the time is passing.
So normally, we are pretty aware
of how much time has passed
between two very
important salient stimuli.
And the idea is to try to understand
how is the brain keeping
track of this timing?
So, I train the animals
to perceive two different time intervals.
One is gonna be short,
so it's of half a second,
and the other one is a long
time interval of two seconds.
For the animal, this is long, you know?
For us, it's very fast,
but if you do it too long,
then the mouse can get distracted.
So what I do in order to study that,
now I'm gonna share the screen of this,
the screen here.
Okay, yeah, you can see the screen.
This is the first time
that I do it like this.
So let me know if you have any problems.
So what I'm going to use
in order for the animal to basically,
perceive these two intervals of time
and also make sure the animal
is actually paying attention to this,
is I'm gonna implement a
system that's called two,
this is not working
two, forced choice task.
So the animal has two,
basically, what is gonna happen
is that I'm gonna give the animal
these two different stimuli,
which is the interval.
And it's given by applying one
tone on a specific frequency
at the beginning of one trial.
And then the time interval is gonna pass
between when I applied the second tone,
this is the second stimuli.
So in the case of a short interval,
it's gonna be half a second as I said.
And if it's a long interval,
the second tone is gonna come later,
at the two seconds around, okay?
So the animal has to basically
perceive these two tones.
And then the animal has to tell me,
basically if it perceive
a long or short interval.
So I'm gonna just present
the animal to a water spout
so the animal can then...
So if I have the mouse,
like I have a mouse, here,
the mouse is gonna
perceive these two tones.
And then it's gonna have two spouts
where water is gonna come out of.
And the animal has to,
if it perceived, by example, a short tone,
the animal has to lick from one spout
and then it's gonna get the water reward.
If it licks from the other spout,
then it's gonna get a punishment.
And if the animal perceives a long tone,
then the animal needs to start
licking to the other spout.
So that's why it's called
a two forced choice task
because the animal has
only two choices to make.
So you're forcing the
animal to make two choices
and it's either licking right or left.
And in this case, for example,
if it licks to the right,
it's gonna represent
that the animal perceive a short interval.
And if it licks to the
left, it's a long interval.
So I'm gonna be training these
animals to be doing this.
So if I go back to this
Zoom, I start my camera here,
okay, how can we move the camera?
Okay, to the iPad?
Yeah.
Okay, so here it is.
It's basically the room where I work
and this is how basically
the set up looks like.
So I'm gonna push it out
of this box a little bit.
So you can see here, the
kind of things that I use.
So this is a set up the build
out of optomechanical parts.
These are mechanical parts that you use
for different optical studies,
how to build microscope,
you use these kind of parts.
And then I also custom made
different parts like these,
this is a spout holder like this,
this is a bulb holder.
I- all of these things, but we do it with,
we use a 3D printing machines.
So I design them what I need,
and then I 3D print them
here in the university.
And I also use some electronics.
So in order to touch,
to sense which spout,
these are the spout,
wait, I'm sorry,
the lights turn off because
I need to be normally
in the dark.
If the animal been perceived,
for example the short interval,
and it has to leave this spout.
I can touch it
and you will see the light down there
of that capacity sensor, that's the chip,
that is sensing the changes in capacity.
So it's gonna sense
the touch of this spout
or the touch of this other spout.
Then I have an entire electronic board,
this is an Arduino board,
maybe you guys are familiar with that,
in which then is gonna sense
that one of the spout is being touched.
And if the right spout is being touched,
I'm gonna activate these
very tiny waterfalls.
So they're gonna just
deliver a drop of water
and everything is basically
controlled by a computer.
And I can see the animals
using a regular wet gun.
And this is basically another role
that is gonna deliver some air
because if the animal makes a
mistake, I just punish them.
So normally, I have another
set up that I'm building here.
So this is the same idea,
a little bit cleaner.
So normally, the animals
will go inside this tube
and I will head fix it here.
And then the animal is gonna be exposed
to the different stimuli.
And then it can touch either
one or the other spout
in order to leap and get a reward using...
And everything is controlled
using these things.
So, if you don't have any more questions,
then I can also explain to you
the rest of the experiments
and we stop sharing this one.
- [Lena] Francisca, can I
ask a question for a second?
- [Francisca] Yeah.
- So you do need to have an
engineering background, right?
In order to do what you're doing,
because I see you're designing
some of the things, right?
- Actually, I don't have
an engineer background-
- [Lena] You don't have, okay.
- I studied by biochemistry.
I honestly have no idea what
I'm doing most of the time,
if I'm completely honest.
And I think that's the
beauty of doing like a PHD
or keep doing science,
is that you're always learning new things.
So my background is in biochemistry
and molecular genetics.
And then I started going into neuroscience
and I learn about the brain.
I learned how to feel the stuff,
or how to execute behavior.
And then you design the paradigm
and you have to build it.
And once you are exposed
to this challenge,
you're like, "Okay, how do I tackle this?"
And then you ask around.
And they told me,
no, you use these kinds
of microcontrollers
in order to control all these behavior.
Okay, then I learned how to do it.
I practice, and everything requires
just learning new things constantly.
So I don't have any engineer background.
I just try to do my best.
The last time that I built a solar,
(muffled) was when I was in high school.
And I was like, I dunno,
15 years ago or more,
and I had to relearn everything
and then ask around about
different strategies
that you can use, basically.
So no, you don't need
an engineer background,
you just need to try to
do your best, I guess,
I think that's my point.
So then, one thing that I wanna do,
so the animal, and I
wanna show you one thing.
Okay, the animal is executing a behavior,
and I also wanna know
whether there are specific
parts of the brain,
which are important for this behavior.
Does anybody know any technique
that could tell you which brain
area could be involved in?
I don't know, in executing
one behavior, licking,
or in my case is keeping track of time.
Anybody thinks of experience
that you can maybe do
in order to figure out which
brain area is involved.
No, in the brain, we have
like different cortical areas.
Some of the sensory neurons,
you have motor cortex.
Yeah.
- [Lena] Chrishana you wanna?
- [Chrishana] Yeah,
someone proved it, yeah.
MRI was what I was going for.
It was like do activities
based on keeping track of time
and then scan the brain accordingly
to see where you can see
activity in the brain.
- Exactly, there are some studies
that they've done that with humans.
So they put them in FMRI scans
and they look at which
brain areas activate
when you have a task that
involves keeping track of time,
and that actually is something I read
before I've been building
my project or my hypothesis.
And you come up with different brain areas
that might be interesting to study.
So, I don't have FMRI machine
in the lab for my mice,
that's kind of expensive.
So, sometimes we don't need it.
So how do you think I can in a mouse
prove that whatever I'm looking,
in a human FMRI,
it's translatable to the
mouse brain, any guess?
Electrode patches?
It can be electrode patches,
but the problem is that
the brain is kind of big,
and I can not just put
electrodes everywhere.
I'd have to select an area.
So I'm not doing electrophysiology,
I'm actually doing imaging,
and I just put the microscope.
I look at specific areas
and it is like an electrode patches.
I'm gonna record the
activity of these neurons,
but how do I make sure
this is whatever I'm seeing in a recording
that looks like these neurons
are keeping track of time
are actually important
and you need them to keep track of time.
And about the mice,
you normally buy them from companies.
These are genetic things,
very specific brands of mice.
If I see by example, that in my case,
I am interested in an area
called the (indistinct).
So if I see that the activity here
has some patterns that involve timing,
how do I make sure that this is necessary
to have this pattern for
anyone to execute the behavior,
any guess?
Okay, so I'm gonna show
you ways that we do it.
So one cool thing that
we have available now
is that if we have a neuron,
so I'm gonna draw like a classic neuron.
- [Lena] Someone said,
open the mouse skull.
- I do open the mouse skull,
but then you see the activity.
It's like, how do you make
sure that it is necessary?
Maybe you can deplete
the neuron, the area,
you can open the skull.
You can remove the entire brain area
that you're interested in
and see whether the mouse
can execute the behavior.
But it's a little rough,
right now we have better thing.
So we have a neuron, it's kind of ugly,
I'm so sorry about that.
And neurons, they communicate
and they fire these action potentials.
Now you have like action
potentials for me now.
And how do I know that these neurons
it's important for my behavior?
What I do is I use a bio-engineering tool.
So I'm gonna express inside these neurons,
a specific receptor,
a receptor that is not
normally expressing,
but I engineer.
And these are receptors based on opsin,
like the ones that we
have in our eyes, okay?
So opsin, basically, these receptors,
the idea of these receptors,
if I shine light, like
a photon to these opsin,
then the opsin is gonna get activated.
And what's gonna happen
is it's gonna induce,
you can either induce action potentials
by opening these opsin
and allowing sodium,
again the light, sodium
to come into the brain.
And this is how you depolarize a neuron,
or in my case, what I'm
gonna do, is allow chlorine.
And chlorine, what it does to the neuron
is gonna hyperpolarization.
It's gonna induce hyperpolarization.
So what happened with that
is that you are gonna basically eliminate
the ability of the neuron
to send action potentials.
So it's gonna be flat, like flat,
nothing's gonna happen.
So the practical idea is that to a mouse,
I'm gonna have a mouse.
No, this is a very ugly mouse,
I'm so sorry about that.
To a mouse, I have the brain of the mouse
and I'm gonna express the opsin
in this specific area that I wanna do.
Then what I'm going to do
is when the animal is
executing the behavior,
I'm going to shine light directly here,
the photons light,
and I'm gonna inhibit
that area of the brain.
And so I'm gonna do that,
especially when the animal
is perceiving their time.
And if I see a disruption on the behavior,
then you can pinpoint the area
and say like this area
it's actually necessary
for the tracking of time.
Because if I inhibited using these opsin,
I'm gonna disrupt the behavior,
the ability of the animal
to keep track of time.
So this is actually,
(indistinct) that was
developed by engineers.
So you basically take a protein
that is not supposed to
be expressing the brain,
but if you put it in the brain,
you can modulate the
activity of the neurons.
So you can either inhibit these neurons,
or you can activate these neurons.
And that's a more precise way
to modeling neuronal activity,
comparing to just by example,
removing some area or
applying some broad anesthetic
in that area.
So here I can inhibit
the neuron specifically
during the time the animal is
perceiving the time interval.
So if I show you here, let me see this.
Okay, so if I show you here,
these are the optical fibers that I use
to deliver the light in the brain.
So here is what it drives my LED,
these are LED drivers.
And what I'm gonna show you is done.
Whenever I wanna basically
inhibit the neurons,
I have my fibers here.
Okay, so this is hard because
I don't know where it is.
Yeah, okay, and I can turn on this
and there's blue light coming out of this.
So you can see blue light
and this light is gonna go
directly to the mouse brain.
And it's gonna inhibit
the area specifically.
So I'm using,
tools are meant for
electronics and computers.
So I have this blue light that I can,
again, trigger with a microcontroller
and then illuminate the brain directly
and judge whether a
specific area is involved
in proceeding time or it's not.
- [Odaelys] Fransisca, we
have like two minutes left.
- Yeah, we have two minutes.
So it's very short.
I will love to show you
how the animal does it,
but the idea is that then
you have the behavior
and you can inhibit
the brain specific area
and determine whether you need this area
in order to execute the behavior.
And the idea here is that for
these neuroscience research,
you use engineering tools,
I actually use a lot of programming.
So I program in Python a lot,
all of these is in Python.
And we use all these molecular tools
in order to express these different opsin
inside the mouse brain.
And we also need to learn
now a little bit of biology
to know how the mouse behaves,
and how to treat animals and do surgeries
and all this stuff.
So, this is very fast.
I wanted to show you how you can actually
inhibit the neurons,
but you can imagine that the
mouse goes into the setup,
then the animal just proceed both.
And if I turn on the lights,
then the animal is not gonna be able
to basically judge the time interval
that it's being presented.